hello there today we're looking at
implicit mle back propagating through
discrete exponential family
distributions by mathias sniperd pascal
minervini and luca franceski
this paper is a paper that we've
discussed in our regular paper
discussions on discord and so it is
informed by everything that i have heard
there
if you want to take part in these
discussions and influence my opinions
you're very welcome to do so the link to
the discord is in the video description
all right let's get into this paper
right now
this paper proposes essentially a
discrete
layer for neural networks this is maybe
how i can describe it and the basic
setup is in this figure right here so
let's say you have an input x which
might be some sort of a continuous input
like an image they do give an example by
the way the authors they have quite
helpful
code that's available but also they have
made themselves a little video about the
paper and i also recommend that you go
watch that video because it's quite
helpful so
what they give as an example in the
video which i find a good example is you
have a map of and they use i think they
use even warcraft uh maps but you have a
map and uh you know there's like a lake
somewhere and then there's like a little
little house right here and so on your
task is to go from the top left here to
the bottom right so you need to plan
your way somehow through that now you
don't get this as a graph that would be
directly input into dijkstra's algorithm
however you get this as an actual image
right
yet the
the um
the solution here is going to be some
sort of a some sort of a path some sort
of a gold path that's the label
um or maybe something even derived from
the gold path like how long the gold
path is so maybe that's five long or
something like this
so it's very complicated you first need
to recognize where can i even go based
on the image on the left uh then you
need to find the shortest path based on
you've determined where to go then you
need to evaluate based on that shortest
path you need to evaluate some property
for example as i said how long is the
shortest path or just you know follow
the shortest path on the actual map
so it's a mix of continuous and discrete
elements
and specifically the part in the middle
that's described by this p of z right
here that is going to be some sort of a
discrete solver in the case here it's
going to be a shortest path algorithm
now the question is how can we run back
propagation if we only have the label on
the right hand side how can we back
propagate i mean we can back propagate
from the label through here right this
is a neural network that maybe
determines some property of the shortest
path
but then how are we going to back
propagate through this layer right here
back to this neural network that's
supposed to extract the input graph to
the dijkstra algorithm from the image
and that is a challenge there have been
some
solutions already for example uh some uh
one famous example is a score matching
ah sorry that is also an example but the
famous example is the straight through
estimator
um
however that it doesn't always work
it fails sometimes and specifically here
the authors propose a different
framework in this implicit mle framework
i'm going to look at how that's built up
this is a very technical paper and i'm
by no means an expert in these things i
just try to give you a little bit of the
idea of what's happening right here
so that you know what's going on and if
you have something like this in your
neural network like a combinatorical
optimization solver or anything like
this then you can just go grab their
code and use that as a layer it is
really super simple
all right that was the overview now
let's get into the paper
hold on this video is sponsored by
weights and biases weights and biases is
your one stop shop for all your machine
learning needs it will track your
experiments with a single line of code
it'll upload automatically all your logs
all your configurations everything to
your cloud it will automatically grab
all the output all the metrics all the
configurations of your experiments and
store that in one neat location so you
can see your experiments you can track
them wherever they run you can compare
among the experiments but you can go
further you can then tune your hyper
parameters according to the results of
those experiments and all of this is
done automatically in a distributed way
you can literally sit on your toilet on
your smartphone and tune your
hyperparameters and start new
experiments but it's not only experiment
tracking and hyperparameter tuning
weights and biases has tools for the
entire pipeline of machine learning
research from the initial idea up until
the deployment and beyond that when you
actually want to track what you've
deployed weights and biases has cool
methods to track all of your data set
and their dependencies to each other as
well as your models and all kinds of
other artifacts that you might produce
they're very powerful visualizations for
all the inputs and outputs of your
pipelines as well as the models
themselves all of this runs in the cloud
but if you're concerned about privacy
there are options to self-host the
system is free for personal use and for
academics and they have great plans for
enterprises small teams large teams
doesn't matter so thank you very much
weights and biases for sponsoring this
video if you don't know them yet
absolutely check them out it's free
it'll make your life a whole lot easier
now let's get into the video
[Music]
as i said uh the
the
the the problem right here is that you
have these kind of um these kind of
discrete tasks sometimes as a part of an
entire learning setup
so the paper
makes different contributions but
here are they here they're listed out
they say we propose the implicit maximum
likelihood estimation as a framework for
computing gradients with respect to the
parameters of discrete exponential
family distributions so what we want is
of course gradients gradients of this
discrete process in the middle and the
discrete process specifically is going
to be formulated as a exponential family
distribution and we're going to see how
that happens
they say we show that this framework is
used for useful for back propagating
gradients through both discrete
probability distributions and discrete
optimization alg
sorry optimization problems
and that would be the example right here
would be
a a dijkstra shortest path algorithm or
an integer linear program solver or
anything like this in fact
their one of the general formulations
they have is for integer linear program
solving
imele requires two ingredients a family
of target distribution q and a method to
sample from complex discrete
distributions we propose to families of
torque distributions and a family of
noise distributions for gumball max
based sampling so we're going to check
look into how that works and
exactly what it contributes
and then
yeah we show that this simplifies expl
to explicit
maximum likelihood learning when used in
some studied settings
and experimental evaluation these points
were probably not going to go into too
much essentially in point four they show
that um
for some settings this uh reflects
already established methods so it's in
sort of a generalization of methods that
have already been around of methods that
are maybe specific to a given setting or
problem and the experimental results
well
you just
like their experimental results
essentially show that their method for
example out compete the straight through
estimator method so what's the deal with
discrete things in neural networks the
problem is of course that we can't
compute gradient with respect to
discrete things now take for example
the straight through estimator the
problem it's trying to solve or one of
the problems you can formulate it like
this you have some x you put it into
neural network and out in the middle
somewhere
you
it you are required for some reason to
sample
from some sort of distribution for
example you're required to you this
produces a
produces a probability distribution over
a few classes let's say over four
classes
and then what you're going to do is
you're going to sample one of the
classes right here and then you're going
to continue with that
through the nest the rest of your neural
network until you're at the label
now again as before you need to back
propagate in order to learn through this
network which is easy
but through the choice through the
sampling procedure of that
of that inner layer and that's hard so
what the straight through estimator does
is um it's it's a bit of a trick it
essentially in the forward pass you do
the discrete optimization you do the
sampling but in the backward pass you
you
act as if you
simply propagated the distribution as
such
so
for the to the forward pass it is really
a discrete sample but to the backward
pass it looks like you simply uh you did
you never sampled you simply passed the
whole distribution and say well i'm not
sure it's like 70 this and 30 this the
way you would implement that usually is
you have some signal uh let's call that
h um
for for maybe that's the histogram um
right here
and what you would do is you would
if you sample from h that was going to
give you like
s
well let's say let's say we take the
most likely state right so we determine
h and we we take the most likely state
which
which is let's say s
is the
um arg max
of h okay
that is your sample
now what you would do in your forward
pass is you compute the next layer h
prime as
um
s
which
and then plus h
minus
a stop gradient
of h so the stop gradient um
am i doing this correct no
of course not
um
yes oh yes i'm doing this correctly of
course
okay
so
let's analyze this in the forward pass
the stop gradient has no effect on the
forward signal so these two here
essentially cancel out these cancel out
to zero however in the backward pass
right since uh derivation is distributes
over addition and subtraction what you
would do if you were to derive
the gradient of h prime that's
essentially the gradient of s plus the
gradient
of h plus the gradient of stop gradient
of h
now
stop sorry minus
minus
stop gradient of h obviously has no
gradient so that goes to zero
the gradient of s
is also zero because it's a discrete
operation and most of these frameworks
simply tell you well the gradient is
zero it's a discrete optimism uh
operation if you're not sure that this
is happening you may in fact also put a
stop gradient operator around s and you
can see what remains is the gradient of
h
so you see the trick in the forward pass
these two cancel out however since in
the backward pass this by itself is
already zero because of the stop
gradient operation
the gradient of h remains right here
this is a trick you can you can
simply swap out a gradient in the
backward pass for whatever you like with
this trick
people have used this
to get gradients with respect to
discrete operations like this
but this paper right here is an
alternative and as they show in some
situations it is more appropriate to use
that alternative however it is also
quite a bit more tricky
so what's the first thing we're going to
do
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to take that inner
thing right here that inner procedure
and again let's go back to the
task of
um
of finding the shortest path so what's
the input the input is some sort of a
graph right
where you need to find the shortest path
with
cost associated with each of the edges
and um
some some start and some end goal
and what we want is the shortest path
some sort something like this
now
the first thing we're going to do is
we're going to encode this problem into
a binary vector now how exactly we do
this is uh is
i don't really know for for shortest
path problems but we're going to encode
this into essentially well not a binary
vector but
i'm going to encode the problem
into
this vector theta right here
so theta
in this case what you would do is
your theta vector let's
this is the theta vector it will have
i guess
it will have probably for each edge it
will have an entry with the negative
cost of that edge associated in the
vector so the negative cost of edge one
the negative cost of edge two the
negative cost of edge three now why are
we doing this you can see that
we are going to multiply
this theta with another vector called z
and z
here is the let's call it the solution
or the proposed solution to this inner
problem
and z is now a binary vector
so z can either be 1 or 0 in each entry
and it's going to be 1
if
and only if this edge here is part of
the proposed solution so any path in
this graph can be represented by a given
z variable right
by simply setting a bunch of things to
one and zero
i can i can
select some of the edges and if i have
selected correct ones they will form a
path and if i have selected
the absolutely correct ones they will in
fact form the shortest path you can
immediately see that for the shortest
path the inner product between the two
vectors will be the highest among all
the paths right
so this is how i formulate my problem
i'm formulating my problem between
as an inner product between a binary
vector and some sort of a weight vector
theta
such that
for the solution of the inner problem
like the shortest path algorithm or the
k subset selection or the integer linear
program
such that for the solution of this
problem it is the case that this inner
product is the highest
possible now you immediately see that
of course i can make that inner product
even higher by putting all of the edges
to zero right so you know z right here i
can simply say zero zero zero zero zero
all the costs here are negative
ergo i have no negative cost ergo that
is going to be zero and that is going to
be the largest possible i've solved the
problem
what's the problem this isn't a
path in the original formulation
so the last ingredient we're missing
right here
is what they sometimes here call
capital
c
this thing right here capital c is a
constraint set so capital c
would define in this case
what the valid entries for the z vector
are so z must be in this capital c class
and
i think c must be in the yes uh
that defines what the valid
valid
valid solutions even look like
so in the simplest case if this is a
classification problem right this is a
classification problem
um
theta would sort of um
yeah
you can you can think of this as a
classification problem and then z would
be selecting the class right
you can model theta in this case as just
a vector of ones
and then z right here could select the
class by simply putting that entry to
one
wherever
of whatever class is selected and
the constraint set c could be easily
modeled by saying
the
norm
what is that
the sum of all the entries which is
probably the one norm
of z must be equal to one
right that could be the constraint set
am i correct here
i'm not sure i can actually model
i probably can't model it like this like
here there probably needs to be like uh
there probably needs to be some some
sort of cost per class or something like
here and then i can model the constraint
as saying the inner product of z with a
vector of ones
must be equal to one
that looks better so that is actually
part of the
definition of the constraint set
and the
the problem in these cases is that this
constraint set makes it very difficult
um
on
on obtaining good gradients through this
discrete um through this discrete
problem because right here as you can
see it's it's not really easy because
most of the z vectors in the dykstrap
problem aren't actually valid paths so
um
the issue here is that we need a
gradient we need to respect the
constraint set
of the problem
they go ahead and they formulate
this as i said as this
problem where
you have a vec this vector z is whatever
solution you propose
the theta is the definition of the
problem the inner product is sort of the
the the reward let's say the yeah the
reward maybe the inverse loss of the
problem
and
they can now formulate this as a
exponential uh family distribution by
simply raising
this
by putting this inside of an exponential
function let's see if they've done it
somewhere
right here look at that oh it's not even
a it's not even a minus sign
all right
so for now just
trust them that it is necessary to
formulate it as a distribution um and
and don't
just kind of hang in there
it is going to get very
complicated but it is going to lead
somewhere
so they can formulate this inner process
as a probability distribution
p
of z
um
where that is according to the
exponential family so as i said the
exponential family here you put in this
thing right here there's a temperature
at which you sample
so what is that essentially is going to
do is going to normalize
you know given this right here this is
the the log partition functions the
normalization constant this is
essentially going to give you a
distribution
over
the individual dimensions of the z
vector and that is going to be
normalized and is going to be more peaky
or less peaky depending on the
temperature right here so the process
that they formulate this as is
you take some input x right here you put
it through the first neural network to
obtain the theta the theta is
essentially the problem definition for
the inner
algorithm
the inner algorithm you formulate as a
probability distribution so it's going
to have more or less likely states with
the more likely states being the ones
that solve the inner optimization
problem
perfectly to more reward
so z is going to be a random variable
that is according to that distribution
for now you can just think of z
as a random variable
and the likely states of z
are the ones that have the paths that
have a very short path through the in
our example
or whatever states solve the inner
problem very
accurately
and then from that z we're going to put
that through another neural network
that's going to give us our output and
we're going to compare the output with
the gold label
and then we're going to back project
through all of it our parameters are the
parameters here
and here so the parameters of the two
neural networks f u right here
this is easy to do right because we can
simply back propagate from y into the
neural network and the parameters of hv
the v parameters this is hard
this is the hard part
so
what do we need to do in order to back
propagate all the way to
h sorry to the v variables
well what we need to do is we need to
the the direction here is that
the parameters sorry
x
becomes
theta
z
becomes y
this is with the help of the parameters
um
v and this is the help of the parameters
u right u is easy for v what we need to
do if we want to have the
that what you can see right here the
gradient with respect to v we first need
the gradient with respect to theta and
then we can
once we have the gradient with respect
to theta
where is it
i guess here
once we have the parameters with respect
to theta
we can use the um
the back propagation algorithm again to
back propagate into this network and
change the weights v
so how do we get the gradients with
respect to theta
again this
is
means we have to back propagate through
this piece right here
which is the inner optimization
algorithm
so here is it here is the the chain rule
expanded
this is this here that's theta
um
and so we need the parameters the
gradient with respect to theta and then
we can use backprop
okay
this by the way is the entire algorithm
as it's going to be
later
you can see it's fairly simple you can
also see there is a lot tech mistake
right here but i think that's my
conversion
so
the what they do is they say this it's
very hard it's very very hard to compute
this gradient
with respect to
this inner optimization procedure right
it's very hard to compute a gradient um
with respect to the dijkstra shortest
path algorithm essentially
you'd have to know how do i need to
change my graph definition in order for
the path to become shorter or in
different in some way right and that's
very hard like all you can do really is
kind of try and see what happens
i wouldn't know anywhere anywhere else
because
yeah
remember that what the theta is
the theta is the output of the first
neural network so the theta
is the definition of the graph
and that is produced by by this neural
network right here that looks at the
picture and gives you the discrete graph
so essentially what it gives you is an
adjacency
an adjacency matrix but still
so the question is you know how does my
adjacency matrix need to change for the
dijkstra algorithm to find a shorter
path let's say a shorter path
or
well or
a path that is more close to the gold
label that i have because you don't
always want to shorter you actually want
to learn from data
so the first step they do in this
challenge in this sub challenge right
here is they say um
this is too hard we're going to replace
the loss right here
this loss the true loss
of our output compared to the label with
a surrogate loss
this l is an implicitly defined a
maximum likelihood objective
and we're going to calculate its
gradient instead of the gradient of our
true loss
now
the logic of how we get there is the
following
in this inner problem
we define a probability
this probability distribution remember
what is this
p here
p describes the solution space of in our
case the dijkstra algorithm so p is a
distribution that would assign high
value
to or high likelihood two
paths
that are very short in the graph that's
defined by theta and low value two paths
that are very long
in this same graph right
now
what we can say is can we
this is essentially a distribution can
we find a different distribution what we
call a target distribution where we can
show that in expectation the loss
the loss from this target distribution
right here is always smaller than the
loss from the true distribution
so essentially can we find a
distribution that where
the paths that it outputs are
lower in loss lowering the final loss
than the ones we have
so
remember we have x and all of that and
the end there's y right
we predict y and we compare the y to the
true y there's going to be some loss
and the question is can we reduce that
loss right here
so we don't necessarily want to find uh
theta such that we find a shorter path
but we want to find a more appropriate
theta in here
such that
the rest of the neural network can
predict y-hat more accurately in order
to be closer to y
for in the in our example
we want to
if
if our neural network right here is very
bad at actually extracting a proper
um
walkable graph from the landscape right
here like if it doesn't recognize that
this is a lake you know it thinks yeah
all of this is really fine to walk on
and so on the graph right here will be
quite crappy the weights on the edges
will be not accurate right
it's not inferred correctly from the
landscape
um that means that this network here
will have a pretty hard time determining
the actual value of the shortest path
because even though the dijkstra
algorithm does a good job of finding the
shortest path
it's on the wrong graph and therefore
it's useless so what we need to be able
to do is we need to be able to more
accurately
extract the graph from the image so we
need to train these parameters right
here
so
here we ask ourselves can we come up
this distribution p here that's the
distribution of solutions
to the problem that's defined by theta
we ask ourselves can we come up with a
distribution that has a lower loss
than the
distribution we have
and the answer is going to be
yes we can do so with a simple a simple
let's say trick
so if you look at back at this
i realize we're in like three layers
deep of problems like we have a problem
for that we have another problem to
solve for that we have another problems
of our current problem is that
we want to see can
can we change this distribution such
that the loss is lower how do we need to
change this distribution essentially
and
the answer is going to be
we're going to take the output right
here
and we're going to pass it through this
network
we're going to look at the loss we're
going to back propagate that loss until
the point where
this algorithm stops
and then we're going to take one
gradient step into the direction right
here
and then that is going to be our new
distribution so what does that mean in
our example right here
um we're going to take the graph that we
output right here
we're going to run it through dijkstra
gives us the shortest path remember this
is a crappy graph because our network
initially is not good
we're going to
put that through this neural network
right here that determines the cost and
we're going to
calculate the loss and back propagate
that
so what does that give us ultimately
that tells us
well
the gradient says
what
how do i need to change the output right
here in order for
the neural network that follows to do a
better job
right
and
let's say the output is
well
this edge here
has a bad weight
or in fact this edge there's an edge
right here that's missing or
or something like this nah sorry
no that is formulated wrongly
what we
are going to change is we're going to
change obviously the z which is the
solution so
it's going to say in the shortest path
that you computed there's something
wrong
for example you should have
maybe taken a a different shortest path
or you should have weighed it
differently or something like this
and we're going to take a step into that
direction
so
for example if the shortest path rather
than up and over should have gone
directly we know that the edge right
here should have had maybe a lower cost
associated with it or something like
this so we're going to use gradient
descent
to
see how do we need to change the inner
problem
such that
the rest of the pipeline does a better
job
and that's what you see
that's what you see
right
here somewhere
there okay so this is the target
distribution
is um
this right here so it's the same as the
regular distribution of inner solutions
however instead of inputting the graph
as it is we're going to input the graph
minus
a step size times the gradient
of the loss with respect to the output
of the inner
with respect to the output of the inner
solver
so this is using gradient descent
in order to come up with a better
problem definition right here
since these two are vectors they're
multiplied together we can use in fact
the gradient with respect to z and
subtract that from theta because they're
of the same dimension right
um
so
we're going to ask ourselves what would
be what would be a more appropriate
problem definition
in order for
the rest of the network to do a better
job
and that's going to be our so-called
target distribution and now
our job now we have a pretty simple job
our job is going to be well can we
make it such that the current
the current graph
that we output right here
is more like this target graph so can we
make the distribution p more like the
distribution q is the same as asking can
we make
the current graph that was output by the
network h more like the
graph that would be more optimal for the
rest of the network
and that is let's say a solvable problem
in fact if you work it out
the formulas get pretty simple so if we
do it like this
and by the way this inequality here is
crucial obviously because um
and but we see why it's given because of
gradient descent we're in expectation
guaranteed that the q distribution is
going to have a lower loss than the p
distribution because we do one step of
gradient descent with respect to the
loss right
so essentially we do a step of gradient
descent in the inside and then our
surrogate loss is going to be well can
we make the output distribution more
like
the result of that gradient descent
this this must be one of the most
confusing videos ever but i hope you're
still
with us
uh so
what we want is to make these two
distributions closer remember
we said we can't back propagate through
the discrete optimization procedure
so what did we do we said instead of
back instead of back propagating through
the inner optimization procedure we're
going to replace that by a new objective
the new objective has two steps step one
determine what would be what would be a
better output
for
um
for the discrete sorry what would be a
better input for the discrete
solver
and then step two is can we make the
input that we've received
more like the input to the discrete
solver right this is
where
this
we do the gradient descent
inside
and how are we going to make
distributions more like each other
that's this right here this is the kl
divergence between p
the actual distribution and q the target
distribution and that's going to be our
surrogate loss that we use instead of
the
uh loss that we cannot differentiate
if you
if these are both exponential distribute
exponential family distributions you'll
see that uh this pretty easily cancels
all cancels out and reduces and in the
end the gradient of this surrogate loss
simply going to be the difference
between the two marginals so between the
two means of the distributions
now
this seems pretty easy
but
inside of the three layers of problems
we get another problem so what does this
mean
this is
the mean of the exponential family
distribution when given a certain
definition problem definition theta
prime or theta if you're over over here
this
given that it's a
let's say it's a hard problem with these
constraint sets and so on calculating
the mean of such a distribution is hard
it's in fact probably uh as hard as
as uh solving the
the the entire
problem itself
so
calculating the mean of these
distributions is not an easy task
sampling from these distributions
straightforwardly is also not an easy
task
so
what this paper does is it says
for under certain conditions what we can
do is we can replace the mean with this
and this is
a trick well a trick a method that they
call
perturb and map
and by map they mean maximum of
posteriori
so essentially means that
for the exponential distributions what
we can do is we can approximate
the mean
using
map the most likely state
and
what's the most likely state for example
in this dijkstra
algorithm the most likely state is in
fact the shortest path by how we dis how
we'd define the problem
right so we've defined the problem as
the inner product between the problem
definition and
the
proposed solution now what's the most
likely proposed solution if likelihood
is given by the inner product obviously
the one
that maximizes the inner product which
is the one that
by construction has the shortest path
okay
so
fairly convoluted but this is something
we can actually do so we cannot
calculate the means of these
distributions
but we can calculate the most likely
states
and it's not so straightforward in fact
it is a better estimate so they consider
i think
yes so here computing the marginals is
in general a
what's that sharp p sharp hard problem
scales poorly with dimensionality
so map states are often used to directly
approximate
uh the
the means
however it's apparently better if you
use this perturb and map this
strategy
where
you estimate the mean not directly as
the most likely state but as an
expectation
sampling from a noise distribution
uh and perturbing this state
what does that mean
that means that
you can get the mean of the distribution
let's again draw our dijkstra graph
right here
like that like that
you can get the mean
of
this distribution
by
well
by slightly perturbing the problem so
maybe slightly
re-weighing the edges saying this edge
is higher this edge is now lower
um slightly perturbing a lot of times
and then every time you calculate the
shortest path so most of the time like
this will be the shortest path most for
most of this but then every now and then
you'd perturb it so hard that you know
this edge now goes up very high in cost
so then you'd have this as the
um
shortest path right here
and so on but ultimately
yeah so
adding all of that up getting the
expectations over all the shortest paths
in order for a lot of perturbations will
give you a good approximation of the
mean of that distribution
the last question is a little bit okay
what noise distribution is appropriate
for this and the answer is going to be
the answer is going to be
that is going to be a gumball noise and
i think this is this now gets a little
bit uh too deep but
just
to mention this right here
if in fact there are
some properties are given and the
specific property that
needs to be given for this to be
accurate is that you can define the
problem always such that
such that
the constraint set
is given
by a number k
where
you can see right here exactly k entries
in z have to be one
if that's obviously not covering all of
the problems we've considered but it
covers a lot of the problems we've
considered
and even if not you can still apply it i
size as they say it's just not as
appropriate but still appropriate enough
and they also have a way to sample
gumball distributed random variables
but i don't think necessarily we need to
go into that you just need to know that
the appropriate noise distribution in
fact to get a good estimate of the mean
is a gumball noise gumball distribution
by the way
it describes extremely values so if you
want to know
the distribution of
of the maxima
of some phenomenon um that will be
gumball distributed
and
then you have it at the end of the day
you would
the this surrogate gradient would be
given
by the difference between
perturbed
maximum
sorry the maximum
posteriori
solutions of
perturbed
thetas
right here
and
yeah
so this is a few layers steep let's
actually look at the entire algorithm
and you'll see it's not that hard
so what do we do
in the forward pass
we take x and as i said we get theta
this is a neural network in our case it
takes a picture and it extracts the
adjacency matrix which is theta so it
extracts the graph
that we're now going to run dijkstra on
okay
so this data goes into this forward pass
right here
what do we do
in fact we
forward propagate
the
maximum a posteriori state of
a perturbed version of theta
and
this here
if you remember this here is going to
give us the mean
that's a wrong mu
is going to give us the mean of that
distribution
that we're looking for
okay so it's going to be forward
propagated
in
so that
is going to be forward propagated uh
to
let's say to
the
second neural network and that's going
to give us y or at least an estimate of
y and then we're going to compare to the
real y we're going to get the loss and
now we're back propagating right
so back propagating we take the loss we
go back we go back
through this first neural network until
we're here and that is where this starts
so the backward pass
that would come in here right this
gradient here
that's the gradient we get from the
chain rule in the backward pass we also
need this step size
lambda right here
okay so what are we going to do we're
going to take
that
gradient
and rather than giving it straight to
like the straight through estimator or
to the
the chain rule we're going to compute
and update
to the theta to our graph definition
right to our adjacency matrix or our our
cost
cost matrix for the shortest path
algorithm essentially saying how do i
need to change the problem definition
for the dijkstra algorithm in order to
in order for
the upstream sorry for the downstream
modules to do a better job predicting
the correct label why
that's so we're going to compute an
updated theta
then we're going to compute a
um
this surrogate loss right here and the
surrogate loss
as you've seen
right here is going to be the difference
between
the two
max perturbed maximum of posteriori
things so it's going to be uh
by the results that we've derived where
was it where was it here by these
results right here remember
this is the gradient
this is directly the gradient of our
surrogate loss and the surrogate loss is
can we make
the output of the first neural network
closer to something that's more useful
so
the gradient is directly given by the
difference between these two things
so by the difference of marginals which
we approximate by the difference of
maximum posterior so this requires us to
run dijkstra once here in the forward
pass and then it requires it to run the
extra again here
once on the on this updated graph and
the difference between the two is going
to be the gradient
in which we have to update our inputs
okay
notice that
um
i've talked i think a bit
confusingly so here i already said
how do we need to update our problem
definition right
and
you could think that you know
we could feed that directly upstream but
we can't the real gradient we want to
feed upstream is right is this thing
right here so essentially the top thing
is how do we need to change our
problem definition
so the downstream neural network can do
a better job and this right here is that
what
or sorry how does the upstream network
so the one that maps x to theta how does
that need to change its behavior
in order um
to
produce a better input to the solver
yes that is the least confusing i can
say
and then we return the gradient
that gradient that we computed and this
is our substitute gradient for
the gradient that would be
this is our substitute gradient for the
gradient of the true loss with respect
to theta and since it's a gradient with
respect to theta we can continue back
propagating
through here backpropagating it into
this neural network here and update the
weights
so that is it the only thing i'm not
sure about is if they really
return the
z-hat right here like it was my
impression that in the forward pass they
would actually feed the true
the true
z
uh upstream but
i
i'm not sure because
for example where was it
um
yeah here they rely on
z bar which is z bar is
essentially that's mu
so not sure exactly we might might have
to look at the code exactly but i hope
you understand a little bit of of what's
going on right here um
yeah so recap
we have some discrete part in our neural
network like a shortest path algorithm
or some other combinatorical solver or
even
sampling uh from or taking the top k
elements from some distribution
something like this okay this is
not the entire algorithm but this is one
layer in the neural network right the
layer
really requires a discrete operation to
continue
the question is how can we back
propagate through that in order to
update
the rest of the network
specifically these upstream parts right
here that are in front of it they need a
gradient signal from the loss that's all
the way over here at the end
so what do we do
we use this algorithm right here
we forward propagate
let's say we for propagate regularly in
the backward pass we first compute
a better
uh a target distribution uh prop
a parametrization of the target
distribution
which essentially means
we are going to
construct
a better problem definition
uh a better problem definition that
would make the downstream life easier
so making the downstream life easier
means that we move into the direction of
the gradient
of that downstream loss
we move with a certain step size
and then we ask ourselves well having
this target distribution now
can we make
our in our upstream modules
such that they
provide the solver with something that's
actually more close
like the target distribution
and that
is
exactly the gradient with respect to
theta and that is going to be computed
as a difference between two marginals as
we've shown
and we cannot compute the marginals
because these distributions are very
complex they have these constraint sets
and so on but what we can do is we can
compute most likely states that's
exactly what these solvers do
and if we
compute the most likely states of these
perturbed
inputs
that is going to be a good
approximation a good estimator for the
marginals
and there and then at the end we get the
gradient
the substitute gradient that
approximates the true gradient with
respect to the input
okay i i just i want to highlight how
why this is so complicated it's because
essentially we have no idea how to back
propagate through
like a dijkstra's shortest path
algorithm the question is how do i need
to to how do i need to change the the
input right here uh such that something
based on the output changes in some way
right for that i essentially need to
know well if i change the graph a little
bit like if i up weigh this edge right
here how is the shortest path going to
change
and this is not a continuous process
this is a discrete process right it's
not going to change for a while until i
up this too much and then all of a
sudden
the shortest path is a different route
like it's really discontinuous
so
what we're going to do and that's going
to be
a problem of selecting the hyper
parameters like the lambda
and the the temperature of the
exponential distributions is going to be
how exactly like how
how noisy do i have to make this process
to get an actual estimate of how my
outputs change so essentially what i do
is i
perturb so this
adding
adding this noise right here
i change my graph a little bit like this
right and then sometimes the shortest
path is going to change if i do this
you know a million times then i have a
good idea a little bit of
how is my shortest path changing with
respect to an input change okay so
that's essentially what i do but the
problem is i need to tune the hyper
parameters if i change too little the
shortest path is not going to change at
all and i'm going to have no idea you
know what how i need to adjust because
there's no gradient if i change too much
the shortest path is just going to fly
around wildly
changing every time and again i have no
idea how to change anything in order to
go into a specific direction
so that's the challenge right here and
the additional challenge i don't want to
do it a million times for each forward
and backward pass ideally i want to draw
one sample and have that sample be a
good low variance estimator of what i'm
looking for
cool
so i've also like i've left out part of
this like entire part of this paper that
you can still look at if you so desire
but this is the basic idea again you can
take this
there's code you can take it like inside
of a layer i think i have it open right
here it's it's available there's code in
torch and in tensorflow they give a
little bit of an example of um
this is not the entire algorithm this is
a little bit of an example of one part
of that algorithm to
essentially
show this inner routine where you have
to come up with good set of problem
definition so here you see the
essentially the let's say the true
problem um
this is
on the left you can walk on the right
paths and you cannot walk on the dark uh
squares
and um
you can see
that if you for example sample
the
if you don't sample at all if the
temperatures are set to zero then
this is what you get um it's it's you
can see kind of uh the shortest path but
it's not really good right um
if you up the temperature a little bit
and let the algorithm do some
exploration on you know
using the in inner algorithm you can see
that over time you get a much better
much clearer picture
of what the supposed landscape is is
looking like so this
again this is not the entire thing this
is just this inner part
it's an illustration of why you need
appropriate amount of noise for that
inner part you can see that over time as
the algorithm infers
uh
the
essentially the
every time it solves the shortest path
algorithm um
it gets a good idea
over time
of how the landscape looks like
all right i invite you to read the paper
check out the code check out the video
that was made by the authors themselves
it's surely linked somewhere
i'll link it um
it'll give you a fresh perspective
and with that and thank you so much for
listening i'll see you next time bye bye
oh there's experiments well
okay
well there's experiments they're better
than other stuff
cool excellent bye